まあ読み方わかりませんが
中国語の読み方にした方が通じますけど
老人にでもしましょうかね
まあ老衰かもしれませんね
いわゆる老いることなんですね
年取っちゃうんだと 年取っちゃ年ではないんだから老いるんだと
それもあるんです 全ての現象にあるんです
物質に で 連続はするんです
連続はすると同時に一個一個老いていっちゃう
老いて 老ってしまっちゃう
老う？老ってしまう 老いるんですね
それ毎日見てることでしょうね
テープレコーダー見ても
1年間使っちゃうと 同じテープレコーダーのテープレコーダーなんですけども
落ちこぼれになってるんですね
もう老ってしまう で 細胞の分裂は何でしょうかね
同じ細胞がきちんと分裂はするんだけど
新しい細胞は生まれたばっかしでピカピカ元気だよと言ったっても老いてるんです
ですから 我々の細胞は別に古い細胞を一つ持ってないんですよ
誰でも もう 3ヶ月間 ほぼ 3ヶ月間でしょう
1個細胞 1個の年というのは
ですから どんな人の細胞でも年取ってるわけじゃないんです
1年古い細胞を持ってる人はいませんから
ほとんどの細胞はもう 3ヶ月間ぐらい
せいぜい 3ヶ月間ぐらい古いんだと
その 3ヶ月古いものも体から出ていっちゃいますから
でも なんで我々の体と子供の体が違いますかというと
そこら辺なんですね 我々の細胞自体はもう
老い どういうふうに老ってますかというんですか
だから老いる 老いてるな
老いるという言葉 動詞を使いたいんだけど
難しいことは知ってますけど
老いるという動詞をどう変化するかということは
僕にとっては問題です
ですから とにかく老いてます
老いてきますということで
老化しますということ
一つ一つ増殖すると同時に老化もする
3番目に出て 4番目に出てくるのはアニッチャタ
ここでアニッチャタというのは無常ですか
無常性とか書いてますね
で ここで無常性の意味と経典で言ってる無常性には少々違うかもしれません
じゃあ一つ例えば 何か我々はものを持ってきます
持ってきたものが まずそのままでいない
変化する 1番目の変化っていうのは
外からいろんなエネルギーをもらったりする
それは金銀宝石だったらありがたいことなんですけど
別に外からエネルギーもらうのはありがたくないわけもありますね
花なんか買ってきたところで
外から熱エネルギーいただいたりしたりするとどうなるんですかというと
もうすぐもう悪くなっちゃいますから
でもエネルギーは吸収する
で 次に同じものは自分で連続して増殖して続く
続けている 次に増殖して変化していくんだけど
新しく生まれるものはどんどん老化していっちゃう
年取っていっちゃう 次にどうなるんですかね？そういう風に年取っていったところで
もう同じもので増殖することを変化することはできなくなっちゃうんですね
エネルギーを吸収することも不可能になっちゃう
自分の状態はもう進むこともできなくなっちゃう
老化して老化して 違う現象にならなくちゃいけない
このテープレコーダーを見ても
それ見えるでしょうね
電池を入れ替えて入れ替えて入れ替えて入れ替えて使ってはいるんだけど
いつかはもう使えなくなっちゃうんですね
ゴミになってしまっちゃう
もうテープレコーダーでなくなっちゃって
ゴミになる それは確実にそうなるんです
それはもう いかに努力したっても止まることはできない
今我々が読んでいるテキストにしたっても
買った時は新しいもので
で 毎日これは外からエネルギーをもらって元気出るんですね
これをこれにしたっても
ずっと外からエネルギーもらってるんですよ
テキストも そうでなきゃこの本はこのままいないんです
例えばこれは全くどうですか
水っていうのは一滴もないところに置いておいてください
どうなるんですかと 全部この粉々になってしまっちゃうんです
ですから この本の中にある水分子
水分 水分子が外へ出ていく
それから空気からまた新しい水の分子をいただくとか
空気も同じく中の空気は出ていく
外から空気をいただくとか
そういう風に自分が新しいエネルギーを入れていれて生きているんです
同時に自分の特色をずっと守っているんです
来週になったらアビダルマのテキストは週刊誌になっていくということは全くないんです
それはアビダルマのテキストでの議論です
でも  1年  2年経つと またこの本は老化はしていく
また何年か経つと もう使えなくなっちゃう
ゴミにクソになってしまう
そこで最終的に全部壊れてしまうことは
アビダルマでは無常性と言う
それにはそれなりの時間がかかるかもしれません
花だったら 2週間とか
本だったら年  20年とか
人間だったら 80年とか
最終的に消えて壊れて終わりになったということは
それなりに時間かかるかもしれません
それはどんな現象を見るかっていうことなんですね
人間は 80  80年 あるいは 100年で死にます
で言ったっても じゃあ細胞から見てみましょう
人間はいませんから 細胞はあるんだけど
じゃあ細胞は何歳？どれぐらい年取りますか？ 1年もないでしょう
ですから 人間の寿命と言ったっても
まあ 3ヶ月間ですよと言ったっても
全然過言ではないんです
人間は細胞の塊であって
細胞は 3ヶ月間で死ぬんであって
それだったら人間の寿命は 3ヶ月間だけですよとは言える
DNA なんかはもっと早いんです
すぐ壊れる アミノ酸とかね
ちょっとしたことで壊れる
それだったら 3ヶ月間もいないで
人間の寿命は短いんです
だからどんな立場で見るかということによって
寿命の長さが決まってしまうちゃう
そこで仏教はそれを知ろうところで見ているんだから
瞬間も消えていっちゃうんだ
それっていうのは 光の速度の速さで変化するんだから
ですから 無常もそういう風に自分が見たい立場から見えるんです
そこでどんな 色にもどんな物質にもあるものがこれですと
このラッカナですと そう
色ですと 色と言ったって特別な色ではないんです
特別な物質ではない 物質のある特色で集積性
それから層析性 それから老性
それから無常性という性質はあるんです
で 私はちょっと前言ったんです
こちらで無常ということと
経典の無常はちょっと違うのではないかなと
経典ではこんな風にきめ細かく分析はしない
でもでも普通の人間というのは
仏教で無常無常と言ったら
いきなり何を言ってるんですか
仏教っていうのはおかしいではないかと
すっごい知識人のように喋って喋って反論するんですね
自分こそ正しいことを知ってるんだと
なんだかんだ無常と言ってすごく暗いんではないかと
自分たちがすごい明るい考え方を持ってるように思ってるんですね
みんな この何様のつもりかわかりませんだけど
仏教の無常の話で言うと
誰でも反対はする で 仏教の人々はそれに全然混乱はしない
なぜかというと まあ所詮人間はまあそんなもんだと分かっているんだからね
全く智慧っていうのはもうないどころか
現れる見込みもないんだということは
まあとことん言ってるんだから
かなり苦労しないと かなり頑張らないと智慧っていうのは現れませんから
無常っていうのは鼻の先で見えてるのに
いえ そんなことないんですよとと言ってるんだから
ですから どうせ無常と言った途端
人間反対する 考えちゃう
例えば人が死んじゃったら腐るでしょ
そうすると人間考える
これ腐ってるのはこの微生物は働きますから
それから熱によってこの細胞分解するんだから
ですから 遺体は微生物に微生物に働かせないように
熱で分解できないように冷たくして
それからあの なんとかですか
この殺菌しておけば 遺体は何百何年でも何億万年でも持ちますよと言ったりするんです
それでそういう工夫もするんです
でも だからってそれは永遠に持ちますか？とんでもない話でしょうに
我々はもう何百万年いたわけでもないし
ミイラなんかいるんだ
あれミイラといた人 死んだ人
人間とまた違いますからね
化石とかあるんだけど
あれは化石ですから もう石だから
もう細胞も何もないんです
いわゆる細胞の形に普通の物質が流れてきて石になってるだけ
ただの石なんです ですから
この人間というのはすぐ反対したがるんですね
無常に 無常に反対したがるんだから
あなた方に無常をわかってないのは
現象にはこのウパッチャヤ
サンタティ ジャラタ アニッチャタという 3つの方法あるんだから
皆様方はよくサンタティだけ見て
私の息子 私のおじいさん
おばあさんだと 私の財産だと偉そうに威張ってるんだよ
でもそれはサンタティだけですよ
そちらにまたこれとこれ
ジャラタもアニッチャタもウパッチャヤもありますよと
例えば いくら高価な宝石であろうが
アクセサリーで金銀であろうが
時間経つと変化 新しいものを集積するでしょ
集積したところで 金は汚くなって使えなくなっちゃうし
銀も汚くなって使えなくなっちゃうし
宝石も輝きが消えていっちゃうし
皆様方死んだ宝石見たことがないんでしょうね
宝石死ぬんです あれも集積性から新しく外からエネルギーを吸収するんですね
それで自分の特色が消えちゃうんです
消えて死ぬんです 死んだところで何も価値がないわけですよ
あれ見られないんですよ
宝石 宝石死ぬためにはものすごい時間かかるんです
それはもう何万年でもかかるかもしれませんし
早く死ぬものもありますけどね
で 宝石出るところ探すと結構あるんです
死んだ宝石っていうのは
それはもう何にもなりませんと
みんな捨てます そのまま石として
ゴミとして あれやったっていうのは
ポリスにしたっても あまりただの死んだ石だし
でも元々はこれはルビーでした
元々はこれはキャッツアイでしたと言えるんです
すごくため息するんで
その時は すごくいい客体になってるものでね
これはもう死んでるんだけど
これはもう本当に生きていたならば
もう何だる面倒だとか言うなりますよ
ことがね いくらそういうふうにため息したって意味ない
死んだものは死んでるんです
ですから そういうものにさえ
このエネルギーはそこから吸収して
途中で自分で死んでしまっちゃうんです
ですから そういう風な物事の変化がありました
仏教でお釈迦様のお経で言っているのは
この全部まとめてウペッカーヤ・サンティティ
ウペッカーヤ・サンティティ
ジャラータ・アニッチャーから全部まとめてアニッチャーっていう言葉使っているんです
大体これで種類に向け方が終わりましたけど
結局はありませんね 物質としては
あるのは地水火風という 4つの基本的なエネルギーの波動だけなんです
他のものはなんとか識と読むんですね
もっと基本的なものがあるんだから生まれるものであって
別に元々あるわけものではないんだとと言ってますから
だからこの色識も 4つありますよと言うんだけど
それはただの無常の説明みたいなもんなんですね
でもよく物質を見ると
面白いところはそういう風になるんですね
細胞を見ると 細胞は新しく生まれるんだから
我々はずっと新しくね
すごいピカピカの体でいた方がいいのに
やっぱりそこに老化現象っていうのが出てくるし
老化現象してしていっても続ければいいんだけど
いつかもう二度と細胞分裂できませんぞと思って
それでピタッと止まっちゃうし
そういういろいろものがあるんだから
そういうのを観察して
それから体だけではなくて
物質の世界もそういうふうに観察すると
そういう無常論は生まれてくるんですね
ですから こちらは色は二つもない
で終わりましたから この 15番目にサンガーガーターというところがあるんです
このサンガーガーターっていうのは
このだいたいこの本を書く場合は
第1章 これにはこういうこういう項目がありますという
書くのは現代的な書き方なんですね
昔は本以前 印刷する技術はなかったんだから
手で書いたんだから それから我々の文化では紙はなかったんだから
葉っぱで書くんですね
ですから まあ紙よりは長持ちはする葉っぱが葉っぱでしたけど
ですから この綺麗にでっかい紙は作れません
葉っぱで決まってるんだから
大きさは ですから この第一章
これこれこれだと書いたっても
そんなにうまくいかない
ですから それ一つで芸文にまとめて頭に入れたり
それから最後に入れたりする
今まで種類の色を分析して
それから全部分析した色を一つの項目にまとめて
5つの芸文に入れちゃう
それはこの色相は何々でしたか？っていうことなんですね
それを覚えておけば もう簡単に全部覚えてしまっちゃうってことです
ブータッパサードーヴィサヤバーオハダヤンイッチピハダミッチピジイタハラルーピーアッターラサヴィダンカタパリッチェドーチャヴィンヤッティーヴィカーロラッ
カナンティチャアニッタンナダッサダサチェティーアッタヴィーサヴィダンバヴェッティー
そういう風に考えてくださいと
大衆 4つがありましたとかね
いわゆる大衆の時代の
それから常識はあって
それから共識があって
それから正式があって
それから神識と命識がありましたと
色識が色識色識があったと
それで合わせて18と
それから分断識と標識と変化識と相識と
そこで20種類ですと
そこでこのこれこの非感とどういう意味ですか？この漢字が
非感触 非感触ってどういう意味ですか？実はパーリ語ではアニッパンナというか
アネシパンナアネシパンナという
この別に特別に現れたものではないという意味なんですね
この非感触と書いているのは
別に色ではないという意味なんです
で 前の 18にはなんとかの形で色としてのエネルギーがあるんですね
後から説明した 10種類には色としてエネルギーは何もないんです
ただ  18種類の色の特色の言ってるだけなんですね
そういう意味かな わかりませんだけど
非感とか非感触と書いてますが
で それからもうまあ それ分ぐらいの説明で十分だと思いますが
色の世界は どこまで行けばいいかな
本当は 193 ほどから始めた方がいい
一応そこら辺ちょっと読むだけにしましょう
で 一部は終わりましたね
物質の分析の 2部はルート・ヴィバーク
これから色はじゃあ分別してみようと
この分別するっていう言葉は
この日本文化ではあまりこの好ましくないんだけど
仏教で 特に初期仏教とテーラワーダ仏教っていうのは
このヴィパッジャワーディーと自分のことを言うんですね
大乗仏教は自分のことを大乗仏教とマハヤーナと言うでしょ
我々は自分たちのことはテーラワーダというよりは
ものすごくヴィパッというようなヴィパッジャワーディーと
いわゆる分別するんです
存在はもう消えるところまで
こまこまきめ細かく分析するんだと
物事はそのまま説明しませんと
いわゆるこの総合的に大雑把に
特に大乗仏教徒がやってるように
全てはとか 一切はとか
いつでもそういう話でしょ
色はこうだとか 全部この全体的に全部まとめてなんだかなんだかとか
そんなことはもう間違ってるんだ
ありえないんだと 例えばヴィパッサナーテーラワーダの人にご飯は美味しいですか？と言ったら答えません
これ分析してみなきゃと
真理はそんなもんなんですね
それはまあ東洋人にとっては美味しくて
西洋人には美味しくないと
僕らの分にそういうもんなんです
ご飯は美味しいですよ
ご飯はやっぱりご飯食べる人に美味しいんであって
パン食べる連中には美味しくないんです
ですから それはその通りや世界一美味しいのはご飯だよというバカもいますけど
それは仏教ではそういうふうには言わない
それはまあ分析する それでご飯は美味しいと言ったって
一生食べたくても美味しいもんじゃないですよ
ご飯でも 例えばもう今ちょっと疲れていて
四時まあ今四時ですけどね
じゃあご飯食べようと想像してみてください
美味しいとは気持ち悪くなるんじゃないんで
それよりは何かケーキとかなんとか
他のせんべいでもいいんだけど
せんべいとお茶あればそれはもう気持ちいいんだけど
今すごい豪華なご飯があったりすると
やっぱりそんなにやっぱり
ですからご飯美味しいですよではなくて
それ時間考えなくちゃいけない
その人の体の状態考えなくちゃいけない
いろいろことを考えて分析しちゃうと
もう何も言えなくなっちゃうんです
とにかく真実は分析しなきゃダメなんです
相対 総合的にトータル的に喋ったらもういい加減なんです
ですから このテーラワーダ仏教の特色は
もう本当に分析している
とことん分析している
ですから 別に分析している
何でも分析できませんだけど
こういう現象は分析しますけど
その特色だけ守りましょうということで
イバジャワディバガワと言うんです
逆さんは分析論者だと
ということで 分析しないでまとめて
すべては梵が一理あるかというならば
それは邪見であって 邪教やと簡単に決めてしまう
まとめちゃったんだ そこで
ありとあらゆるものの中で
森羅万象の中で何か同じ一つのものがないかと探すのは
またちょっとした心の間違いであって
そう探すならば何が見つかるかというと
無常を見つかるんですね
あるいはこのウペッチャヤサンターラジャラターヌティティたちが共通しているもの見つからないんです
最終的に 分析していっちゃうと
残念ながらブラフマンもアートマンも見つからないんです
神も 神も仏も見つからないんです
いくら分析していても
物質の中である仏性は見つからないんです
じゃあそれで色の方分析
それだけやってやりましょう
で サッバンチャパナヘタンルーパンアヘトゥカンサッパッチャンサーサワンサンカタンローキヤンカーマーバチャランアナラムマナンアッパハータッバンエーワティエーカヴィダン
タ
アッジャッティカ・バヒラディヴァッセナ・バフダ・ベダン・ガッチャティ
分析と言ったらこれ分
分別 分別と言ったっても
まあまあちょっとしたおかしい分別ですけど
まず色っていうのはある一つのものとして見る
みんな全てまとめて見たがっちゃうんですからね
じゃあそういう風に見ると
すべての色はムイン アヘートカン
ムインというのはこの
今まで聞いたことがないかもしれませんだけど
これ因縁がなくて生まれるという意味ではなくて
特別な用語でトンジンチとフトンフジンフチという道徳を決める因なんです
例えば我々はトンジンチで行動すると
それは悪いことでしょ
それからフトンフジンフチで行動すると
それはいいことなんです
ですから 物事は道徳判断する場合は
我々が使う基準がトンジンチとフトンフジンフチ
これ それは色にない 物質にはない
いわゆる道徳的に判断は関係ない
物質には罪たる罪になる物質と善になる物質とあるわけじゃない
ただの物質 ですから アヘートカンと言うんです
次にサッパッチャヤ でも物質は偶然に生まれるものではないんです
いつでも因縁があって生まれるんです
偶然に生まれてくるんだったらありがたいんだけど
なかなかそうはないんです
それなりの因縁があって物質が生まれるんです
それが世の中で大体みんな知ってるんですね
物質の世界を大体知ってるんだから
やっぱり因果法則で物質は変化しているっていうことはわかってますから
次にサーサヴァ ウロ この物質の世界エネルギーはすごい欲に関係あるんですね
欲というか煩悩というかね
この煩悩は 人間としてはもう無茶苦茶生まれるのはほとんど体からなんですね
あるいは外からなんですね
ですからこの 愚劣というんです
それからウイサンカタ
ウイと書いているのは
このできたものを作ったものという意味で
現象という言葉なんですね
いわゆる本来実体としてあるものではなくて
一時的に現象としてあるものですと
物質は ウイサンカタ 次にローキヤン
それは世間的出世間的で仏教を分けちゃうんですね
世間的というというのは
やっぱり存在の中の問題ですと
物質はこの存在という我々知っている次元のもので
存在を超えた次元には物質はないんです
それから欲界 欲界っていうのは
この存在の次元の問題で
この我々人間のことしか知りませんだけど
いろんな霊魂やら神々やら梵天やら高次元の存在もいっぱいいると言ってるんですね
そこで例えば神になったら
その神々に体がありますかというと
体があるんですね 体があるということは物質があるということなんですね
目に見えようが見えなかろうと
それ関係なく 体がエネルギーがあるならば
そこに物質的な体があるんですね
エネルギーさえあれば
そこでこの欲界っていうのは
この で ちょっとおかしいな
欲界っていうと まあちょっと問題が生まれますけど
どうしようかな で まあ欲界
色界 無色界と存在次元は 3つに分けてるんですね
欲界っていうのは この物質を通して喜ぶ心を刺激する世界
音を聞いて ものを見て
心を刺激して生きてる世界
色界っていうのは物質的な体あるんだけど
外から刺激は受けられません
生きるためにはご飯も食べない
音も聞かない ものを見ない
そういう存在の次元 自分で生きていられる
自分だけのエネルギーで
外からエネルギーは吸収する必要ないんです
無色界っていうのは体さえもいりません
心だけで十分だという世界
次元なんですね 体もいりませんと
我々生きているのは体も必要であるし
生きるためには その体を通して外からエネルギーを
物質エネルギーを心の中に入れて心を刺激する
それを生きるというんですね
ですから 我々は欲界 色界っていうのは体がなんとかあるんだけど
外からは何もなくてもいいんです
中のエネルギーで生きていられるんです
その中のエネルギーは体の中で流れている
このエネルギーが流されるために体が必要だけなんです
無色界になっちゃったら
この体もいりませんということになってしまっちゃいます
ここで欲界ですよと言ってるんだけど
僕はちょっとこの問題なんですけど
僕が考えるに アナーラムマナ
無生縁 無生縁 アナーラムマナっていうのは
この物質には何も認識できないという意味なんです
無生縁ですね 無生縁って言ってもわかりませんね
わかりませんだけど 意味は物質には他のものを認識することは不可能なんです
物質エネルギーはエネルギーとして流れてるだけ
ですから 心には他のものを知っていることは知ってますけど
物質は知らない あるいは私に右手があるということは
私は知ってるんだけど
私の左手はそれは知りません
私は私に左手もあって右手もあると知ってます
でも右手は左手があることは知らないということ
次に非所断ってなります
アッパハータッバン アッパハータッバン
非所断 この断というのは
この煩悩のことを書いて
それから煩悩は断つべきものと書いてるんですね
捨てるべきもので 断つべきもので
汚れるもので 輪廻転生させるもので
解脱を妨げるものは何でしょうかというか
煩悩なんですね でも色は煩悩じゃないんです
物質は 物質エネルギーは自分の存在すらわかりませんだから
ただ変化しているものだから
別に大したこと問題ないんです
物質的なことは ですから
この体 我々から見れば
この体としてのこの物体を断つべきですよとということはないんです
体を放っておけばいいんです
でも他の宗教では体をいじめなさいと
体で戦えとという苦行を教えている場合もあります
仏教ではそんなことはどうでもいいんだけど
ただの物体ではないかと
体がエネルギーくれと言ったら
まあご飯ぐらいあげちゃえばいい汚れて気持ち悪いと思ったら洗ってあげればいいし
まあうまく足が腰やら痛くて動かないと言っちゃったら
座ったり寝たりすればそれは構いませんし
それはただの体のことだから
全く修行には関係ないように見てるんですね
体いじめること でも心にある怒りやら煩悩やら欲やらいろんな
そこが問題ですと ですから
心の汚れはたすべきであって
体はもうただの物質だから
自分のいることさえ知らない
すら知らないものだから
もう気にしない ということで
仏教ではこぎはないんです
この物事にまず体から入りますという日本文化的な言葉だ言葉があるんだけど
僕は全然わからない言葉の一つなんですね
本当に真面目にそれ使ってる人を観察したんです
皆様は知識的にいろいろ説明してくれるかもしれませんけど
そんなもの私は聞いても聞きませんだから
本当に真面目にじゃあ体から入りますよと思ってる人を観察してみたんだから
もう完全なバカだけなんですね
見つかった ただ 自分が何をやっているか分からない
何やってるか 何のためにやってるか
どういう風にやるか ですから
とにかく体でぶつかってやって
やがてできるだろうということなんです
何も理屈なしにやがてできるだろうというような
加減ただのバカです それは僕は観察した人はたまたまそうでしたかもしれませんし
他の人々はまた違うかもしれませんし
やっぱりまあ それは理屈抜きにと言えばね
僕はもう納得いきますけどね
どんなものでも理屈でいくわけじゃなくて
やっぱり理屈抜きに 例えば絵を描きたいならば理屈では描けませんし
音楽でも理屈では作れる
理屈で作られますけど
今コンピューターもありますから
計算しながら でもあんなものは音楽にはならないんですね
ものすごくお腹の中から来てすごい気持ち悪くなるんですね
それは個人差があるかもしれない
私はこのそういう数学的に作っている音楽を聞くと
すっごいもうお腹の中気持ち悪くなっちゃうんで
それよりも昔の私たちのガキの時代の音楽は聴くとすごいアナログ的な音楽だから
まあいまだに気持ちいいです
年前の音楽だったら まあそれはそれ
そういう理屈はいかないところはあるんですけどね
人間の世界ではね そこは体というならば意味はわかりますが
まあそれでもいいんだけど
とにかくこの まあ仏教の話では
この体っていうのは別に修行の対象にはなるもんじゃないんです
修行に邪魔になるものでもない
本当に考えれば邪魔になるものじゃないんだけど
我々は体に執着しているんですね
私は足が痛いんだから瞑想できませんと
私は高血圧だから 1時間座ったら本当に大丈夫かと
ただの物体のこと気になるんですね
放っておけと ただの物体だから
これいじったもいじらなくたってもどうでもいいんだと
そんな気持ちでやらなくちゃいけないんですね
ただの体ではないかと
ただの物体ではないかと
修行は心のことだよと
とやってほしいですね
まあ一応そういう風に一つの言葉で色はまとめようとするならば
そういう風にまとめますよと言って
それから内なる物質と外なる物質と
また 2つに分けますよと言ってます
そこら辺で時間になりましたので
まあ 4時までですね 4
時半までですか じゃあ続けましょう
で あの十処に行きます
アッチャッティガルーパ
バヒガルーパ 内色外色かね
内色外色でもいいんです
内と外と も分かれるんですね
で 物質エネルギーの内と外って何ですかね
宇宙の物質的なエネルギーだから
そこで内と外というのはこの常識なんですね
常識っていうのは このチャックソータガーナジーヴァカーヤ
眼耳鼻舌身という 5つの色なんですね
目と耳と鼻と舌と体の感覚
チャック・ソート・ガーナ・ディワーカーヤ
眼耳鼻舌身という五つ
で その場合はどういう働き方というと
別に目は地水火風でできてますけど
目を通って生命は形を認識する
外の世界 それによって刺激を受けて
見た見たと心を回転させちゃう
それによって生きているんですね
存在続けるんです 耳は眼耳
地水火風からできてますけど
耳を通して音という物質エネルギーを認識する
認識して心を回転させて存在を続けるということで
そこで私というこの妄想概念
主観 生まれるのはこの眼耳鼻舌身という五つの識の働きからなんです
眼耳鼻舌身の働きがさえなければ
ここに私という人がいて
外に外の世界があるんだという世界は消えてしまっちゃうんです
ですから 内たる世界が生まれるのは
この眼耳鼻舌身という 5つの物質のわけなんです
性なんです ですから その 5つだけ内たる物質というんです
内識というんです そこで例えばテープレコーダーには目はないんです
耳もないんです ですから
外にはそれは存在しない
生命には存在する だから生命にだけ存在する物質
識は 5つそれ常識という
なぜ常と清らかと言うんですかというと
この認識できる 敏感だから
外のエネルギーに エネルギー触れたらすぐわかってしまっちゃう
それだ で 次に 17 ワットルーパ
ワットルーパ ワットルーパっていうのは喜識と非喜識って
この 2つのこの喜の意味を僕は説明しました
ワットこの前説明しました
大体もう何回も何回も繰り返し説明すると
もう 100年経っても阿弥陀如来は続けなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから すごい時間かけて定義したならば
それはそのままもう覚えておいておかないと続けなくなっちゃうんです
で ワットルーパ ワットっていうのは
喜と言って言ってるのは
この認識生まれる土台と説明しました覚えがあるんです
例えば目が私たちにあるんです
目があるんだから 目は光
あるいはものの形を認識する
ですから 目は基盤なんですね
形を見るための を認識するための基盤
音を認識するための基盤は耳である
味は認識するための基盤は舌である
香りは認識するための基盤は鼻であると
外の世界を歩かないか感じる認識基盤は体の観測ことであると
ですから 認識を起こす
外の世界あるんだというふうな実感は起こす基盤と言うんでしょうか
元と言うんですか 元ですね
そういう意味で基と言うんです
そこで 二十八種類の識は基識と非基識に分けた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
これはこの瞑想のヴィパッサナー瞑想の二番目の段階でありまして
この分離識に行くんですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想から
この分離識に行く場合は
このそれぞれの人がどれほど仏教を勉強しているかということによって
この瞑想の強弱が決めちゃうんです
ですから このすごい仏教を知っている人は
ほんのかすかに瞑想したっても
膨大なものを知ってしまうか可能性はあるんです
ですから この大体この分離するために必要な情報でもあるんです
ただ 僕はよく言うのは
この瞑想すると これは心
これは体と分析してくださいという単純なことなんですね
で 体として物体を見る時でも
この物体の中で認識を起こす物質がありまして
認識を起こすことには全然関係ない物質があるんですね
そういう風に二つに分けてみた方がどうでしょうかということで
そこで眼耳鼻舌身という五つと心識という六つは基識と読むんですね
眼耳鼻舌身と心識 すべて色識と書くんですね
眼識と耳識と鼻識と舌識と心識
それから心書いて心の色と書いて心識と
そういう六つあります
その六つの中で その六つを土台として
その六つに基づい基づいて認識のエネルギーが生まれるんです
ですから 認識のエネルギーが生まれるための土台になる物質と
そういうことに関係ない物質と二つに分けられます
物質は 二十八あるというならば
六種類の物質は基識であって
残りの二十一は二十二は非基識になるわけです
私たちの例えばこの皆様覚えていますかね
性識ありましたね 二つ
男性識と女性識という
あれは基識ですか？非基識ですか
あれは非基識なんですね
全然それによって認識が生まれません
じゃあ我々なんで自分が男性か女性か知ってますか？というそれは別に
その自分が DNA の中でそういうクロモソーム
クロモソームなんて言いますか
この染色体持ってるのか誰も知ってません
知りませんでしょうし
でも我々は目で見て 体で触れて
知ってるんだから 自分が男か女かということは
ですから それは非基識になるんですね
で 明確に説明すると 全ての体の細胞の中で男性か女性かということはあるんです
あるんだけど 私たちはそんなこと知りません
認識しないということ
認識できるのは眼耳鼻舌身と心識というところです
そこでそれだったら目はあることは知ってるでしょうに
耳あることは知ってるでしょうに
そこでなんで心がどこに回転しているかと場所を知らないかということ
またおかしくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この心臓ではないんだとね
意が心が生まれるのは心臓じゃないなとは私は勝手に思ってはいるんですね
なぜかというと このいろんなところで我々は考えたりするんですね
たまに まあ脳細胞死んじゃっても心どうかで考えている可能性はあります
考えるということは脳細胞の働きだから
考えること自体は脳細胞のこと
でも生きていることは細胞
全部のもの 全てのことだから
いわゆる考えなくても実感がある時がありますよね
例えば寝ている時は考えていない
その時でも心は働いているんです
だからなかなか分からないんですね
この心識って何ですか？ということは
次にドゥアラ・ルーパ・アドゥアラ・ルーパ
こんな分析はどうでもいい分析なんですけど
やっぱり  え？私もまた日本になります
え？え？じゃあ私はそういった
はい やりましょう そこら辺どんな
ところと うん